this kind of movie isn't exactly my
thing anyway so i'm not going to judge
it based on that i think you know if
this is your thing you'll probably think
it's hilarious this isn't the kind of
thing i generally gravitate towards so
like i was always amused i was always
sort of
at least paying attention
but
nothing ever was like oh this is awesome
to me but
if you're a big jackass fan you'll
probably dig it
you know
this is totally my kind of humor
hey [ __ ] i'm ryan wright and i'm
jerry welcome to reasons to see [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] yeah let's we're gonna give
you some reasons to see and maybe not to
[ __ ] see bad grandpa so let's hang
the [ __ ] out
yeah put our nuts in something
giggity
reason to see number one
johnny knoxville
dude this dude is so cool he's he's
pretty cool he's cool i'm talking about
johnny knoxville himself i think oh just
in general in general johnny knoxville
is like you you watch him on interviews
you watch him in jackass or like i just
don't want to hang out with this guy
one-on-one not with his other jackass
friends yeah a little bit like i would
want to hang out with johnny knoxville
on a mellow day he's got the best laugh
too he does
this anything like it but i tried
the point is i tried but as johnny
knoxville has um uh what's the guy's
name irving zissman irving zissman the
bad grandpa he does a great job in it
because it it's so apparent why so many
people are actually like buying this guy
because
he does sort of transform himself into
the role regardless of how you feel
about the movie you know it's like you
do kind of lose johnny knoxville into
this character and you know part of that
is helped by intensive old age makeup
they do but he does like you know he's
really got this guy down to you know
attitudes and mannerisms and stuff like
that and it's it's fun to watch on that
level but he still gives like a level of
heart to the guy whereas just enough
like it's a very little bit amount but
there's just enough heart to the point
where you do kind of sympathize with the
guy at times too and you do kind of like
care enough about the dude yeah because
he's cartoony enough and and you know
johnny knoxville is a competent enough
actor that those moments do hit properly
and he does a great job at [ __ ] like
this dude literally those balls out he's
made an entire career out of [ __ ]
with people
in some of these just oh man he is
[ __ ] hilarious he's entertaining he's
amusing he didn't find him hilarious i
didn't find anything in this movie
hilarious really like oh there were some
moments that got me cracking the [ __ ] up
i cracked up one time
don't ruin it for people that i won't
there were enough jokes in it for me
where i would go
laughter out of nowhere reason to see
number two
the grandson
this kid committed to the role he had
some lines that he had to deliver that
were so like you don't hear a kid say
that [ __ ] and he
he said it with such sincerity and such
realism you know he he had a good
balance of giant knoxville because john
knox was like very over the top and this
kid has more of that like kind of the
office kind of humor very realistic well
there's enough whimsy to the whole you
know proceedings where even though the
kid billy isn't quite as ridiculous as
johnny knoxville is you can see how they
fit in the same world together and
they're really fun to watch play off
each other and just like you said he is
so natural and so adorable the best
thing about it is those two people
together the best thing this movie has
to offer across the board is
them together it keeps the film having a
heart throughout all this obnoxious
craziness hard to tell what's real and
what's not real and everything feels
kind of natural but the outtakes at the
end help out the i got to tell you the
outtake is my favorite part of the movie
it's just it's because you had no doubt
what it was like also when it was real
you know yeah you've seen the reactions
and stuff yeah you see a couple things
you're like oh
i didn't think that was actually real
because i'm not entirely thrilled just
because a lot of the pranks and a lot of
the bits i either saw in the trailer or
were like oh of course you're gonna do
this like a lot of the stuff felt like
predictable pranks to me so nothing was
ever that shocking it was a little bit
on repeat i would find myself going this
is getting boring too oh something funny
just happened to okay i'm back to
getting a little bored again ryan's
consensus enough laughs is the reason to
see bad grandpa enough laughs is the
reason to see bad grandpa yeah i'm not
gonna say this movie is like hilarious i
found moments to be hilarious but
overall it was very intermittently funny
it wasn't like didn't have a
consistentness of me being captured the
whole time jerry's consensus you know i
think if this is your thing
that's the reason to see bad grandpa if
this is your thing that's the reason to
see bad grandpa like this is something i
actually enjoy more than jackass and i
think jackass fans might not enjoy it as
much but they're the target audience
it's like one of those things where if
you know this is for you
you will have a good time alright guys
thanks for checking out our review for
bad grandpa i'm sure you had a great
time yeah so why don't you go ahead
scroll that comment box below
and tell us
what would you put your genital area in
once you're done with that giving us
those nuggets of information why don't
you come over here and stick your
genitalia on this button so you can see
more episodes of reasons to see and
while you're touching your genitals why
don't you go ahead and follow us on
twitter and if you really want to touch
your genitals go ahead and follow us on
facebook well like us yeah and then once
you're done with all that stuff and
you've gotten your genitals out of the
way you're going to want to get updated
every time a new reviewer video is out
so
subscribe
oh
genital humor yeah genitals nothing
nothing funnier than sex jokes right
people nothing crude offensive humor is
the way to go nothing funnier than just
a
ridiculously large ball sack ye
yes a scrotum of epic proportions thank
you thank you someone finally had the
balls to say it